all right what is screech's real name i
don't know it's dustin diamond there's a
bunch of things i heard about you first
of all because you play like kind of the
nerdy character you went out and studied
karate right well actually it's not
because of that but uh i started uh my
dad taught for 11 years i took it when
he was a karate teacher an instructor
well isn't that funny because screech
runs around in that uh
that uniform all the time i don't know
remember that but i've seen it i did a
couple episodes yeah
yeah yeah they wrote that in but you are
a black belt in karate right what type
of karate i started out with shotikan
the move to kempo and then uh met
various other forms from there so you
could kick ass well yeah but uh have you
ever had to use your karate kick ass or
do you stop just before any anybody
below 200 pounds i'm okay with unless
they're like those crazy you know beefy
guys that you can't hurt at all but talk
to me about something people try to pick
on you because of your character you
play they think maybe you're a nerd they
can beat you up they get jealous of your
success right so so do you have to use
the karate every once in a while i have
i have actually i had to defend myself i
knew what was the ins what was the
incident uh oddly enough it was
disneyland i went to disneyland uh i had
a girl right i'd receive five thousand
fan letters a week and this one girl
kept sending letters years after year
you had to beat up a girl i know
no this uh this girl was like seven
years old she was a big fan of mine she
had watched it since she was like four i
guess okay and uh and i decided she was
in orange county i live in orange county
i told her i'd take her to disneyland
for her birthday right and so i showed
her how old was she at this time she was
uh she was just turning eight wow yeah
and i went i took her to disneyland with
her parents and they were all excited
and and it was a nice gesture and some
guy uh at the time was i don't i forget
how old i was you know 14 15 or
something right and uh this guy was
shouting out stuff to me uh and he was
in the boat ahead of me on the pirates
of the caribbean ride right and that
when we got off the ride he was waiting
for me oh yeah and he tried throwing
like a swing at me and stuff and did you
deck him screech threw them into a wall
yeah yeah really they took they took me
back to mickey mouse prison they have no
kidding yeah it's like a real jail cell
where they hold you until the anaheim
police come and it's got like mickey
holding like a bar like holding the bars
and like crying and stuff it's really
ridiculous